I mean that fossil fuel industry is the
biggest industry in the world that they
have more money and more influence than
any other sector so I mean do it the
more that they can be sort of popular
uprising against that the better but I
think the scientific fact of the matter
is we are unavoidably headed towards
some level of harm so the sooner we can
take action the less harm will result
[Music]
what is your grand vision for all of
this quite a big factory is to get the
cost of batteries down to the point
where it's affordable but batteries are
critical to a sustainable energy future
the Sun doesn't shine all the time so
gonna store it in a battery how is this
gonna help developing nations that have
massive populations that need to have
power so the advantage of solar and
batteries is that you can avoid building
electricity plants at all so you could
be a remote village and have solar
panels that charge a battery pack that
then supplies power to the to the whole
village without ever having to run
thousands of miles from the high voltage
cable over the place it's like what
happened with landline phones versus
cellular phones in love developed
countries they just didn't do the
landline phones they just we're straight
cellulose
we actually did the calculations say
like what would it take to transition
the whole world to its sustainable
energy
what kind of throughput would you
actually need and you need 100 Giga
factories so hundred of these a hundred
of these yes that would make the United
States know the whole world the whole
world the whole world all energy that's
it yeah that sounds eligible that sounds
cool yeah a Giga factory when it's
complete
I'll have the largest footprint of any
building in the world counting multiple
levels that could be as much as 15
million square feet so Tesla can't build
a hundred Giga factories the thing
that's really gonna make difference is
if companies that are much bigger than
Tesla do the same thing if the big
industrial companies in China and the US
and Europe the big car companies if they
also do this then collectively we can
accelerate the transition to sustainable
energy and if government sets the rules
to favor sustainable energy we can get
there really quickly but it's really
fundamental unless there's a price put
on carbon we're never gonna be able to
make the transition that we need to in
time correct yeah the only way to do
that is basically with a carbon tax